مباشره بعد وقوع الزلزال في تركيا والتاكد
من قوته تحول الوقت الى اكبر تحد من اجل
انقاذ الارواح تحت الركام وسائل اعلام
اجنبيه رافقت فرق الانقاذ الدوليه ووصفت
الحاله وقتها بانها ارتباك امر بالطبع
يفسره حجم الكارثه
الفرق اتجهت نحو المدن القريبه من مركز
الزلزال بينما كان الوصول الى مناطق اخرى
صعب جدا طرقا انطاكيا المدمره عطلت وصول
فرق الفرق لايام والطريق الذي يستغرق ساعه
واحده فقط متى يحتاج الى ثمان ساعات كما
ذكرنا وهنا ظهر عائق اخر ارتباك في
التنسيق فحجم الكارثه يمتد ل 500 كلم
الفريق الفرنسي حتى الرحال في مدينه
عثمانيه التي تواجدت فيها فرق انقاذ كثيره
في مكان واحد ليقررات تغيير الاتجاه نحو
انطاكيا التي
فقط لدى استغاثه صحيفه رافقت الفريق ونقلت
معاناته في انتظار حصوله على ترخيص بتغيير
الموقع
بدورها رافقت فريقا امريكيا اشتكى ايضا من
غياب التنسيق الفريق التركي المكون من
عمال مناجم كان دون خبره كافيه وفق
الصحيفه والكل طبعا
ذهبت محاوله لانقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه مثال
على ذلك كان لدى الفريق الامريكي راي
بينما كان للفريق التركي وجهه نظر مختلفه
الفريق الامريكي كان يفضل اسعاف المصابين
تحت الانقاض قبل اجلائهم ونقلهم للمستشفى
لانه علميا بقاء الضحايا دون حركه لايام
يؤدي لتراكم مواد سامه تنتشر في الدم
مباشره بعوده الجسم للحركه
[موسيقى]